let's get back to
china i've got i've got a couple of
questions but one if the us
doesn't do this kind of competitive
thing they're doing where we're going to
do that but better
what's your opinion on the likelihood of
china just being so effective at this
that they do become
more and more and more powerful
so are you asking me more about what's
going to happen with the future of china
because essentially you described what
happens when china has essentially
global dominance uh
if the us uh if the us doesn't
like if they decide okay no we don't
want to go the same route as china do
you think china's just going to
become world dominant yeah yeah yeah for
sure we see that already in europe you
know europe uh we've been criticized uh
that's where i am right now we've been
criticized as having the religion of
privacy right uh yeah you know the the
the new uh european commission's uh
regulations on ai once passed and you
know ratified uh does ban certain types
of ai things like facial recognition
thing uh particularly in high risk
environments like law enforcement
because of issues of bias and so on uh
but there's different levels of risk
assessment and then
with those different levels there's also
different levels of regulation or ways
to actually address and govern those
technologies so we're taking a very kind
of middle road cautious approach the
united states if we are to believe these
documents if they're actually going to
act on these documents that we've seen
on the suggestions uh it seems that they
do want to surpass china and the
hypothetical that they don't
i imagine just the continual fall into
decadence of the united states and
europe becoming essentially the
uh playground for china where they come
to visit because it's beautiful and then
they go back
hmm
okay so then what
that's tricky
it's very tricky because when you have
someone who doesn't play by the same
rules what do you do i don't have an
answer for that it's a really tricky one
i'm not gonna pretend to solve the china
issue
yeah definitely not okay then yeah so
what exactly can you give me some
details about what they're doing over
there
yeah so
the chinese state
ain't no stranger to the powers of huge
bodies with you know equally huge
influence like we have back in the
united states working with intelligence
communities you know google uh so it's
no wonder that seeing the influence that
big tech has on the west
china would crack down on how big tech
uses its weights to influence its users
like using recommender systems and other
techniques that big tech giants have
used to you know rake in the money and
monopolize their power but china won't
suffer any other monopolistic powers
that's for sure
and they state that they have zero
tolerance for corrupt behaviors
particularly those giants that actively
try to consolidate power and capital
capital is trying to become monopolies
obviously the thresholds for this are
super vague and we don't know how it's
actually being implemented in china on a
day-to-day basis it's you know quite
secretive and then we can't really trust
what comes out
still we see that the consequences in in
the west of the unhindered growth of
these giants we already talked about
that and how they become political
actors with their own agendas
uh using the users as currency you know
there's the same if uh if you're not
paying anything for example facebook
well then you're the product
and you know that's not to say that we
should adopt the china the chinese style
of crackdowns whatever that entails uh
i'm sure that would lead to a sort of
equally if not more detrimental over
correction that's usually what happens
when people react it's an over
correction
but i
you hit on it something has to be done i
just don't know exactly
what the best ways to separate these
powers in the west are without risking
that you know extreme over correction of
just you know entirely dissolving them
okay
well
i'm going to let other people deal with
that problem i think i'm going to deal
with something else that sounds a little
too complicated
definitely
that yeah that seems like a real problem
can you
after can you send me over links to
those documents we were talking about
earlier of course you said they're
online okay i'll post those in the show
notes yeah that's great this is this is
the only way right it's we got to get
people to realize this to push back
small acts of rebellion right not
expecting revolutions but people say no
i i won't continue to use facebook i
won't be
their currency right i won't give them
the data that they'll then sell
uh then obviously to the intelligence
agencies also who have full access to
these uh to these systems so it's you
know making getting people informed and
this is this is one way
is there a way that you can like
you can give somebody your data and have
it not be a bad thing like is there any
future where the government
actually does something good with all
the data instead of becomes tyrannical
and
something terrible happens like i i mean
i assume that what they're doing and i
assume that they don't think they're
evil in china right they're like no this
is for the benefit of all our citizens
and there's gonna be less suffering this
way right but we're freaking out about
it so how do we know that it's bad
yeah
it's really
i guess the point of view you know no
other country in history has raised so
many people out of poverty in a single
generation
so you have to you have to ask the
question do the ends justify the means
i'm highly skeptical of the
centralization of power in general uh
particularly when uh
when everything is tied together in
terms of our personal data
when it's also tied to our ability to be
financially independent and autonomous
and these are the discussions that are
being had right now of centralizing our
ability to transact
with our vaccination status
um with our perhaps
what happens when you go to protest and
the government doesn't like that protest
well we see the consequence of that can
you imagine when all these things are
far simpler because they're unified into
a single system that they say it's going
to be highly secure that's horseshit
nothing is that secure someone can
always get in but that's not the i'm not
worried about the people getting in i'm
worried about the watchers who are
actively using that
yeah no that's definitely scary because
like what if things need to change right
what if as a society we're doing
something wrong and you know how do you
even discover something new like you
probably know i've done a lot of work
with diet which goes completely against
mainstream
right so how and just using that as an
example if we're all centralized like
this what happens when there's an
outlier and they're like oh wait but
maybe we should do this differently it's
like no cut that off
easily does not does that not seem
exactly the point
of these kinds of systems they keep
saying it's going to be so much more
convenient as if it's so difficult for
me to pull my license out of my wallet
you know it's so heavy to carry around
that i need a digital version of it so
now you have all my documents you have
the ability to access and to block my
bank accounts and then that's also tied
with whatever new vaccination status you
have whatever that is and then obviously
in terms of identifying people who hold
unacceptable views
right being targeted
when you have
the switch in your hand
so much easier
it seems like that's exactly the point
and we have the power in the east as a
essentially an example of how that's
being played out
okay so say these documents do get
implemented
is there i mean you must have thought
about a timeline like how long do we
have before
we turn into another china
wow
i would say that if
if it's implemented the chinese style
system with these structural changes
as soon as those structural changes are
made uh it's you've passed the event
horizon
everything becomes centralized now can
we actually make that transition
i i'm not too sure i'm not too sure
people realize no we're not going to do
that i think that there's a certain
consciousness growing that's becoming
skeptical of these types of measures it
seems that perhaps governments within
the last year or so have pushed too far
rather than taking an inch they took a
meter right
so that kind of works against them you
take one step at a time and you're able
to do that this was hidden like i said
i'm not sure if the foia request was
granted purposefully in order to
acclimatize people to the idea right
you saber rattle the people in the east
and you go look at if we don't even try
doing this with against them well then
we just become the no the playground for
china
no simple answer but it is scary to
consider what would happen because
i don't trust the the nexis of power